I know you see a hedge behind me but
that's a decent metaphor for what's
happening here this is a hedged open a
modified open they are not going one
phone one hundred percent full bore
because they are worried about capital
controls will there be capital flight
now the predictions we have this morning
are already that the banks are going to
get hammered and there's some talk about
maybe creating a bad bank if you do
create a bad bank could that then
somehow preserve the shares of the
existing bank I believe it will the
problem is that for the time being it
will create such sending balance and
maybe a difficult time for anyone to be
able to make a decision whether they
want to invest or not so then the least
time this takes place the better for the
market it is the first victim is the
market is the market because with the
regulation of the capital flows to the
financial instruments you create an
impeded pyar so the buyers are almost no
not there you have no restrictions of
the sellers so you create an imbalance
market that could create a problem for
the operation of the market the
integrity of the market it's let's not
forget this is the market that brings
the funds to help the medium-sized three
companies
the problem is that they don't have they
know how are they going to create a bed
bank in that case the consequences would
be very limited because there are
already six bad banks with 11 billion
and nobody controls and check what the
money are doing on that so it depends
everything depends if there is the
political knowledge the political power
with no cow of the market medicals can
be done despite all of this problems
about Greece over the last few months
the UN remain relatively firm and I
think we've got to remember that the
Euro really is a good candidate for a
funding currency for the carry trade but
the character it only works when risk
appetite is strong and that means now
with with issues with respected not to
squeeze but China and we've got
political concerns in Turkey Poland etc
that the carry trade is not working
properly and that means that the Euro
remains pretty well supported so within
that you know we didn't see the the
great situation pressing down on the
Euro that many people expend